NARRATOR: Southeastern Turkey,
buried beneath 20 feet of sand,
archaeologists unearth the
world's oldest temple complex--
Gobekli Tepe.
Radiocarbon dating suggests
that the site dates back
to at least the 10th century
BC, a time before the end
of the last ice
age and 6,000 years
before prehistoric man was said
to have developed language.
Gobekli Tepe is really
one of the greatest
archaeological
discoveries of all time.
There are very few
finds in archeology
that really changed the whole
way we look at the past.
And that is essentially
what has happened.
Because our view
of hunter-gatherers
has changed enormously.
We now know they were
capable of coming together
in large numbers with
under, presumably,
some kind of authority to
cooperate on massive projects,
such as Gobekli Tepe,
which involved bringing
huge pieces of stone from
quite some distance away,
carving it beautifully,
setting these pillars upright,
and doing this on
a massive scale.
The very first temples in
the world are at Gobekli Tepe.
And this, in many ways,
changes everything.
Because here we have the smoking
gun of a lost civilization.
It confirms to us
absolutely that at the end
of the last ice age,
there was high culture
existing in the world.
There's no doubt in my mind
that there are question marks
all around the ancient world.
And Gobekli Tepe offers
such a giant question mark
because, according to
mainstream science,
we were sitting in caves,
munching on bananas.
And clearly, that
isn't the case.
NARRATOR: Although to date,
archaeologists have only
excavated less than one acre
of this 22-acre site, what
they have found is astounding--
the remains of a complex of
buildings, massive walls,
and T-shaped stone formations,
some, 9 to 10 feet tall
and weighing up to 50 tons.
Many of the stone
pillars are covered
with relief carvings of
animals, reptiles, and insects.
Archaeologists have
also found figures
at the site that appear to
represent humans with strangely
stylized clothing.
We have no idea what
these humans represent.
We suspect that these are
not just simple statues
commemorating people.
They could be gods.
They could be spirits.
They could be an ancestors,
something of that kind.
NARRATOR: But perhaps
most intriguing
is a life-size statue
found just six miles away
that has been dated to the
same period, the Urfa Man.
This looks like a
person who has come
from an advanced civilization,
who's wearing something that
has much more of
a defined collar,
possibly even some sort
of advanced space suit.
What the heck is he doing there?
His face looks strange.
He's bald.
His head, his eyes look weird.
There's something
unusual about this guy.
And that could be
a clue that leads
us into the mystery
of an antediluvian
or pre-flood civilization.
NARRATOR: Is it possible that
the strange humanoid figure
found near Gobekli Tepe actually
represents an extraterrestrial,
a being from a lost civilization
that existed on Earth sometime
before the last ice age?
If so, does it give credence
to other ancient stories
describing other worldly
civilizations that
once existed here on Earth?
All over the world, we have
giant statues and carvings
of people's faces and heads.
Some of them are
giant colossal heads,
like the Olmec colossal heads.
Others are the
Easter-Island-type statues,
which are huge and depict
people who have elongated heads.
They're cone heads, essentially.
They were giants of yore,
with godlike powers.
In my mind, we would call
them extraterrestrials.
There is this recessed
courtyard in Tiwanaku that
has all these different faces.
These stones were found
underneath the soil,
meaning that at some
point, some type of event
happened that buried
these particular stones.
Some have actually surmised
that they represent some type
of a pre-flood civilization,
that what we have here is,
in fact, a remnant that
depicts that society.